hello I'm a nostalgic guy remember it so
you don't have to and welcome to another
rendition of wtr AKA
was that real this is where we look at
TV shows that may be forgotten by some
but will never by others for just how
strange they were with that said when
you hear the term Steven Spielberg
produced cartoon what's usually the
first thing that pops into your mind
for most people it's usually Tiny Toons
and a maniacs pinkie in the brain
freakazoid or if you wanna go really
obscure you might even think of hysteria
or tune sylvania but there's one that
even diehard fans usually forget about
because even mentioning the name usually
result in a giant doll that of course is
pinky Elmyra and the brain Oh see yep
this actually happened folks not an
episode not a standalone special but an
entire series that absolutely nobody
demanded feels aware of its existence
often ask the same question why these
two elements seem to have nothing in
common so why put them together what to
understand we gotta start at the very
beginning pinky in the brain the two lab
mice bent on world domination from
Animaniacs we're doing pretty well with
their own spin-off show entertaining
kids with the same adult edge that most
feel Bert cartoons had but the studio
was concerned just having the two of
them wasn't enough you know seeing how
show success isn't based on show success
but rather how many toys you can sell so
in the middle of their successful run
the writers were encouraged to put in an
extra character out not a side character
like once they've had before but one
that would be a permanent addition to
the main cast their response was a
surreal slap in the face known as Pinky
and the brain and Larry without
explaining to the audience what was
going on there was a weird occurrence
where out of nowhere a character named
Larry existed and he was squeezed in to
do literally nothing but to Claire
himself as Larry
Pinky and the brain pain is easy to
explain audience is left even though
they probably didn't fully get it but
the message was made clear to studios
Pinky and the brain worked because it
was only Pinky and the brain and if it
wasn't broken it didn't need to be fixed
for a while the stun had worked seeing
how the pressure to include more
characters faded away but in 1998 the
studio had a new idea to combine pinky
in the brain with a character from the
since then canceled show Tiny Toons
Elmyra Duff intended as a little girl
version of Elmer Fudd except instead of
hunting animals to death she loved him
to death
somebody somewhere apparently really
loved this character because she showed
up everywhere they used her and dozens
of Tiny Toons episodes had her cameo in
both Animaniacs and the plucky duck show
they even tried to give her a spinoff
series based on their family that never
got off the ground
well not a bad character somebody
clearly was a user as much as possible
and here she was again now being forced
into a comedy duo that nobody wanted to
do and I mean nobody and I know what
you're thinking Oh where's your proof
that the writers of the show didn't want
to work on it right in the show's intro
every week the title song made it clear
that this was being done under protest
and they send it up in one lyric
why bother to complain there's even
another lyric hinting that the entire
project is out of their control the
earthly manger
some things they can't control their big
cake Elmyra and the brain you can't get
any more obvious than that even the DVD
cover kinda looks a little half-assed I
just draw fast to see we can get a few
bucks out of us so after years of
hearing about this shows existence and
finally breaking down and buying the DVD
is it as bad as everybody has built it
up to be well how do I put this I'm kind
of more disappointed that I'm not more
disappointed I mean yes it's a bad idea
and clearly nobody wanted to do it but
it's still the same people who did
Animaniacs and Pinky and the brain and
for what it's worth it shows not only is
the animation still pretty damn good but
the voice actors are hilarious and the
writing though in a scenario that's hard
to be creative in it's still pretty
friggin funny no joke there's a lot of
times where I laughed really hard
watching this maybe because they knew
this wasn't such a hot idea there was an
extra dose of cynicism that made it a
bit more pessimistic than usual happy
ending there are no happy endings
life is an uninterrupted series of
humiliating failures whatever I think al
maraa seen Titanic a few hundred times
too many let's hope she never rents a
Clockwork Orange almost like the
attitude was screw it if we're gonna be
stuck with this we might as well do the
best damn job we can with it and that's
evident throughout most of the episodes
don't get me wrong these are by no means
masterpieces in fact a lot of stories
feel very rushed with most of them just
being shorts rather than taking up an
entire episode like the original show
but truth be told it does have some
genuinely funny moments not only are
some of the lines funny but the delivery
from the voice actors on some of these
lines that wouldn't get a laugh suddenly
turn out hilarious because of how well
they say it
it fed Finch down ooh the giant order of
ridge was going to tip over his car why
did he order them everywhere
I am truly alone Elmyra look at the wall
hmm
it's a magic doorway run and jump inside
the light
there's even kind of a dark humor to how
much the show loves to insult Elmyra
she's just a little kid but the world
seems relentlessly cruel to her let's
begin the tryouts for the talent show
our first student is oh dear Elmyra but
she's always too naive to realize it so
it never comes across as too
mean-spirited get away from my stall
before I curse you some of the jokes are
enjoyably strange too like the hint in
the opening that somebody from the Brent
Down lab is trying to hunt them down and
you want to know who that somebody is
Christopher Walken yeah no reason why it
just so happens to be Christopher Walken
you gonna run him over with your car
you're a very hostile little man come
see me in ten years I might have a job
for you can I blow up dumpsters yes you
can now go away you depress me it's
beyond bizarre but how can you not
chuckle at that there's also a strange
choice where they take a carnival owner
who was voiced by Tim Curry and just
make him look like Tim Curry yeah
they're just making it look like Tim
Curry owns an evil carnival now for some
reason wonderful just wonderful save
that energy for the next show boy I
laugh a lot sure you're scratching your
head but you're kind of giggling at the
idea too there's also some side
characters are surprisingly not bad well
we never see all Myra's family we do see
her next-door neighbour who she has a
huge crush on despite the fact they he's
just a big dumb boy in fact he's even
voiced by the actress who did Nelson's
voice Nancy Cartwright I'll give you
five bucks if you put a dead rat in the
potato salad where's those jogging mice
this gets especially strange when he
falls in love with the brain disguised
as a little girl named patty Ann and it
forms the most bizarre of love triangles
Elmyra even kind of resorts to
kidnapping it's pretty out there there's
still references to modern day
commentary and there's even some very
impressive writing satirizing the Raven
done entirely in rhyme and for a weekly
cartoon show these are some of the
cleverest rhymes ever associated with
the poem you're demented i asserted
preternaturally perverted i refuse to
acquiesce to you you spawn of incubi her
voice came blaring great game mousies
always swearing no I only was declaring
that your brains a few cells shy so
there seems to be a lot of good about it
does that technically make it a good
show well it depends on what you're
looking for well there are a ton of
laughs there's also a heavier lean
towards smaller kids with a lot more
songs and child-friendly imagery
well the Pinky and the brain show is
never huge into stories they were
usually creative and were given time to
grow here the story seemed more like
excuses for jokes they often don't go
anywhere and usually feel like they're
more stopping rather than coming to a
conclusion there's also the problem that
Pinky and the brain worked because it
was an extreme genius teamed with an
extreme moron but now there's two morons
and a lot of is centered on Elmyra so
pinky almost seems pointless to the set
up on top of that as funny as a
character Elmyra can be she was usually
best in small doses
remember originally she was the
antagonist the person you were trying to
get away from pinky was still a
protagonist so you liked being around
him when you designed the character you
purposefully want to get away from and
then find out you had to put up with her
for 24 minutes it can be a little bit
too stomach
the great irony in all of this is the
idea of a dumb little girl having a
brilliant lab mouse who's trying to take
over the world is actually kind of a
clever show idea it could potentially be
funny if that's why started off as
instead of what we did start off with
but because it's already a combination
of already established ideas that
weren't meant to be that it's not
allowed to go as far as it could so most
of the time we're stuck in suburbia not
allowed to travel to many other places
plus as good as the elements are that I
mentioned before you can never really
get around the fact that this feels like
a forced sellout some ideas even if they
sound like that are strong enough to
escape it but just saying the title
pinky Elmyra and the brain it just
sounds like they're grasping at straws
so if you're wondering whether or not
this is actually we're checking out I
would say yeah kinda is it as good as
the other shows no does every episode
have laughs no before an obviously
forced idea I think it's worth sticking
up for a bit it's a testament that even
though the people behind it had to do it
they still seem to give it their all it
would have been so easy just to not try
and let this crash and burn but judging
by the acting the writing and the
animation it's clear that they were at
least trying to make it work and the
result in my opinion is definitely worth
looking at not just as a valiant attempt
but for some reasonably funny moments I
know it's weird I'm defending pinky
Elmyra and the brain and I'm not even
defending it as anything that great but
with such an idea it's kind of amazing
they got this much out of it in a
strange way it's something to be admired
even if it doesn't always work it shows
that even in the toughest situations you
can turn out something when everybody
expects nothing in hindsight if I was a
writer or an actor or a producer and I
was offered a job like this why wouldn't
I want to work with so many people who
not only have great talent but also
great reputations as fun people to work
with it's still being done at a time
when cartoons were not expected to be
that fun
at least not for kids so if you're
curious enough to say I don't care how
bad it sounds I just want some last from
people I know we're funny you just might
find a little bit in the most unlikely
of places
I mean come on it was a lot better than
this crossover I'm the Nostalgia Critic
I remember so you don't have to
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this one's a real cool one
this is the Starkey Hearing Foundation
this is an organization that travels
across the will to bring hearing aids to
those who can afford them they use
hearing as a vehicle to reflect caring
and change in lives around the world
disabling hearing loss affects more than
360 million people including 32 million
children worldwide yet so many don't
have access to the hearing devices that
can help them this foundation is pledged
to provide more than 1 million hearing
aids to people in need this decade and
currently gives more than 175,000
hearing aids annually many of these
individuals are hearing for the first
time if you go to their YouTube channel
you can see the hearing for the first
time from sports stars two former
presidents too many other celebrities
they're spreading the word on this
wonderful cause to help people young and
old finally listen to the beauty of the
world check out their site or their
YouTube channel and hear the difference
for yourself